by popular demand it's into the woods
the famous Stephen Sondheim musical
actually saw this play in the theater
appreciation class once I remember
thinking wow this is incredibly clever
and really smart but it's kind of not
really my thing
I knew the music was great and in many
respects it was ahead of its time
throwing these twists on fairytales that
now seem to be everywhere but it's not
something I listen to over and over and
over however I also never thought they
would make a movie out of it because
well it's one of the hardest adaptations
you can do on top of so many characters
there's a bunch of different tones and a
lot of uncomfortable adult themes and a
lot of dark elements that really
wouldn't mix well with the movie-going
audience that's looking more for a
musical comedy in this kind of setup
does it pay off well let's look at the
story or stories I should say it's
pretty much all of the classic fairy
tale characters we'll be riding hood
Jack and the Beanstalk Cinderella and so
forth every one of them starts off
wishing for something greater than what
they have
Cinderella wants to go to the ball
Rapunzel wants to be free so on and so
forth a good chunk of the focus is on
the Baker and his wife who just want to
have a child but a crazy witch played by
Meryl Streep comes in and lets them know
that the reason she can't have a child
is because she cursed them because of a
terrible act the Baker's father did
years ago in order to relieve the curse
they had to get all sorts of various
items that tie into the other fairy tale
characters and in a very short amount of
time everybody's running around singing
songs trying to get their goals done and
when everything seems resolved and fixed
it turns out we're only at the halfway
point suddenly all they're achieved
goals and happily ever afters it turns
out isn't what they were looking for or
didn't turn out like they expected
that's the second half of the movie is
actually trying to pick up the problems
of the original problems that they had
in the first half kind of a strange
story layout for a movie huh
especially one that's based on a
two-and-a-half-hour musical and that is
the film's biggest problem this is
obviously meant for a Broadway crowd
with a Broadway audience you know
there's going to be an intermission so
when you get to the halfway point it
looks like everyone's going to live
happily ever after it's really funny to
hear the narrator say end of part 1 with
a movie however your
it's really going to end and you're
going to go home soon and now you're
sort of disappointed where you find out
there's at least 45 minutes left and
remember at that point a lot of people
were checking their watches saying good
lord how long is this movie and the
irony is I actually like the second half
more than the first half despite the
fact that they cut a lot out but again I
can see why it's a movie going audience
and this is really tough to keep
people's attention when it's set up like
this this either needed an intermission
or needed to be two movies and honestly
I can't see that happening in this day
and age not within to the woods well
also the actors are good including Meryl
Streep who's really yucking it up she
reminds me of Glenn Close from 101
Dalmatians but still has those softer
moments too the tone is all over the
place
things that the original show had subtle
or suddenly made extreme and things that
the show had extreme are suddenly made
subtle and sometimes they work sometimes
they don't but to be honest even in the
Broadway play it was kind of hard to get
a feel for it the original show had
really goofy stuff like at some point
they feed the narrator to a giant that's
really funny but then at other points
some main characters die off and in
really tragic ways and they sing these
really sad songs about it's like wait a
minute didn't we just get rid of the
narrator a second ago breaking the
fourth wall how do these two things mix
back then I was very new and
experimental for Broadway especially
considering the original fairy tales but
in a film this is really hard to
transfer over in fact a lot of the
comedy is sucked out to replace it with
a lot of really heavy adult elements
like abandonment issues adultery
separation anxiety mommy and daddy
issues death of a pet death of a family
member death of a friend
responsibilities of husband and wife
don't get me wrong the original musicals
are had these undertones with the big
bad wolf and Little Red Riding Hood but
good god Johnny Depp in this version
they take those undertones and turn it
into holy in your face how could
this be mistaken for anything else
overtones even the song Red Riding Hood
sings to the hunter afterwards I now
hear in a totally different way and it's
really uncomfortable on the one hand I
give them credit that they went full
force and just did it but yeah this is
weird so hearing all this you probably
think I really don't like the movie and
yeah I'm the hole I don't think it works
and didn't quite come together but at
the same time it is such a tough a depth
and as someone who did find the show
interesting I don't regret seeing it
because I wanted to see how they were
gonna try and do a lot of this and some
of the choices are very clever I really
like the visuals when you see Red Riding
Hood in the grandma and the wolf stomach
that was really creative I love the way
the atmosphere really captures the
characters emotions in the second half
just strange because the first half that
has all the Giants and running around
and fantasy stuff it's actually played
very safe not that much grand creativity
it's mostly just done in medium shots
but even then some things that work like
every mare there's a song where
Cinderella's trying to think about what
to do and they actually freeze time that
was a cool effect there's another great
shot when giant Depp howls like a wolf
and we get this cool silhouette I really
wanted more of those but for the couple
that we got it wasn't that bad the real
star of the movie is the music I think
that is one of the advantages to the
film being so straightforward in the way
it's shot is that it allows the music to
really excel you're not really being
distracted by all these crazy visuals
being thrown at you you're constantly
listening to the nice melodies and the
clever lyrics and like I said even
though the second half has a lot of the
songs cut out they still sound pretty
nice I was really shocked at how well
Meryl Streep did with some of the slower
songs I know she doesn't always get the
pitch of the notes right but I thought
she sold it okay in between all the
other goofy scenes she has of course so
what I recommend it only if you're
curious to see how the Broadway show is
adapted because it is need to check out
if you're curious about the choices they
make or what they leave in or take away
it's neat to see as an experiment but if
you're looking for a completed work that
masterfully mixes the complex with the
simple this doesn't quite balance out
I'm glad I saw it but more just to see
how they did it it's by no means awful
and I appreciate a lot of what they
tried to do and I'm happy at the moments
when it really did succeed but it's
definitely a mess and to its credit I
don't know how I would fix it do you cut
out more do you add more do you make it
more visually interesting or do you play
it down even more so the music shines
it's all over I don't know this musical
ever can properly be turned into a good
film but it was a valiant attempt and
sometimes I don't mind checking those
out if you're in the right mood or just
a little curious give it a chance and
see their best effort
you